this is an election year
we're confirming the judge in election
year after the voting
has occurred this is a charade when they
say this is a normal
judiciary committee hearing for supreme
court nomination
hearing is a clear attempt to jam
through a supreme court nominee
who will take health care away from
millions of people during a deadly
pandemic
that has already killed more than 214
000 americans i believe americans of
all backgrounds deserve an independent
supreme court
that interprets our constitution and
laws as they are written
day one of the senate judiciary
committee confirmation hearing for judge
amy coney barrett
this was opening statements and her
opening statement as well
let's bring in our panel fox news senior
political analyst britt hume
molly hemingway senior editor at the
federalist julie pace washington bureau
chief with the associated press
and chris starwell politics editor here
at fox news
host of the new fox nation show
unforgettable campaign commercials
want to check that out uh brit let me
start with you
and that is this is day one this is the
standard opening but there was a
unified message on the democratic side
when it came to obamacare otherwise
known as
the affordable care act yeah you heard
it expressed there by kamala harris
among
a number of others uh that vampy comet
is a sure vote to strike down the
affordable care act of course um she has
no idea
of what amy barrett would do regarding
the affordable care act
and and neither really does anybody else
except
it's worth reminding these democrats
that the of the state of play in that
case
the the the case that is coming before
the court is one in which the
the law was ruled uh that it had to fall
because the penalty that the mandate
penalty had been zeroed out there for
the justification that ju
that justice roberts used for upholding
it um
falls away and that the whole law must
fall away that's what's called
severability it's kind of a technical
issue
it's not at all clear how amy coming
back would vote on that but remember
if she were not on the court and it's
decided by a 4-4 court
the lower court's ruling would stand
and the law would fall away so i'm not
sure at all what danger she poses
when you think about the posture of the
case democrats seem impervious to that
yeah julie pace uh there's the two sides
here senator durbin senator grassley
the republicans on that committee and
beyond are tone deaf
in the middle of a pandemic to be
pushing a lawsuit to eliminate
health care protection the left is also
suggesting judge barrett's confirmation
would be the demise of the affordable
care act and the protection
for pre-existing conditions
that's outrageous as a mother of seven
judge barrett clearly understands the
importance of health care
you know it doesn't seem julie that
democrats have a way
to stop this and maybe delay it a bit
we don't know what we don't know about
the questioning over the next two days
but it seems like they want to get the
political implication of
obamacare out for front
yeah i think that's right i mean
democrats will acknowledge that they
don't really have a way to slow this
down if
amy coney barrett has a strong
performance over the next couple of days
it seems like
that her nomination will move forward
pretty cleanly but what democrats do
feel like they can do is turn this into
a discussion about
health care which is something that the
party did successfully in 2018
during those midterm elections they feel
like when it comes to where
americans are on this question of
retaining the affordable care act
that they're in a stronger position
particularly given the fact that
president trump
keeps talking about having a health care
plan but really has not put forward
anything comprehensive
so if they can spend these hearings
talking about healthcare
they consider that a victory for them
even if it doesn't do anything to slow
down
barrett's nomination molly is your bet
that this is going to get through before
election
well certainly i think it is good to
remember that generally speaking the way
to oppose
a republican nominee to the supreme
court if you're a democrat
is not during the initial hearing
process but to drop a smear
after the hearings have ended that's
what you saw with justice thomas it's
what you saw with brett kavanaugh they
both made it through their hearings
fairly unscathed and that was when
everything broke loose after the
hearings were completed so the fact that
these hearings will likely go pretty
well for amy coney barrett
isn't the end of the story the problem
for democrats and it shows in this
convoluted healthcare argument they're
trying to make
that they don't have a lot of ammunition
and there's not a lot of goodwill
given how they handled that kavanaugh
confirmation
process two years ago that really
unified not just
republicans but really all non-democrats
in thinking that that was a really
unfair smear operation and so there's
not a lot of patience
for game playing or for for what might
unfurl as the week progresses
yeah one of the best republican speeches
opening statements might have been
senator ben sasse who kind of put
everything in
schoolhouse rock terms for the 8th
graders watching and
also referenced judge amy coney
barrett's last appearance and some of
the questions she received take a listen
this committee isn't in the business of
deciding whether the dogma lives too
loudly within someone
this committee isn't in the business of
deciding which religious beliefs are
good and which
religious beliefs are bad and which
religious beliefs are weird
it's none of the business of this
committee to delve into any of that in
this context
because in this committee and in this
congress and in this constitutional
structure
religious liberty is the basic truth
we'll see what we get over the next two
days chris but pure politics
how does this play if it gets through
how does it play if it's after the
election
well you've got to like sass there which
is basically the sassian version
of come at me bro because that's what
republicans have been saying to
democrats about amy coney barrett
which is you want to bring up a religion
again you want to bring up your seven
kids again you want to bring up people
of praise again
please do because we're going to roast
you alive if you try
and that's been the dare that
republicans have been putting out in
front of members like maisie hirono
cory booker and others who were prone to
histrionics and
sort of high school theatrics when it
came to previous hearings to to try to
make these emotional
but to sas's point i don't think for a
lot of persuadable voters they could
care
i don't think that jimmy crackhorn and
they don't care
you take out this case you take out this
matter from the election
i don't think there's any persuadable
voter that's affected i think this is
just going to be
a pretty par for the course pretty
matter of fact
senator sasse also managed to get in the
word jack wagon into his speech uh brett
the the political fallout of all of this
um it is something the president can say
i said i was going to deliver
conservative judges and i did
yeah i think but he already had that uh
established with the two previous
nominees
um i think you know it shows that he's
still got power
and it shows that he's still using it
but i'm not sure this is a kind of uh
if he gets her through and it goes
through without some hideous controversy
arising at the last minute
uh i don't think it adds too much to his
uh strength with voters because the
people who think
amy comey barrett is a good nominee it
should pass a probability for for donald
trump anyway
um i think it could have hurt him if he
didn't make the nomination
um but he did but he did and so i think
that you know this is probably uh
probably a wash politically unless the
democrats
raise something that is considered
disgraceful by most people and hurt
themselves which i think they did
in the end with with the brett kavanaugh
nomination